so first let me ask you about
what the hell is [ __ ] coin is this
connected to
uh to our previous discussion of the
meme
uh does [ __ ] coin cover basically all
coins that are not
bitcoin is it uh
mean is it a beautiful is this a mixture
of both
as with most things in life uh depends
who you ask um
the uh most um uh
kind of enthusiastic and uh uh
parts of the bitcoin community [ __ ] coin
is anything else
right kind of if you ascribe to kind of
a maximalistic view of the world
should crown crumble anything if you
look at people who i would say are
bitcoin proponents
uh yet see value in other things
[ __ ] coin may be the bottom half of the
other things
right so i think again it's really
important kind of who you
ask is how you'll get that answer so
there's tiers
and the way you divide those tiers might
be different depending who you ask
ultimately what it is is it's a meme
yeah and it's used to
uh articulate the idea that
whatever you want to put in that bucket
has no value so [ __ ] coin right are
coins that have no value
yeah uh what is fascinating about it
and i think that again speaks to the
power of the bitcoin community
is uh there was congressional hearings a
couple of years ago
oh no and at one point uh a congressman
from ohio warren davidson who uh who was
definitely
open-minded and uh excited about bitcoin
asked a an individual on the congress
floor
uh during testimony to uh talk about
these other coins and at one point
basically read into the
record the terminology of [ __ ] coin
he said the word [ __ ] coin uh i can't
remember if he said it first somebody
else said or if uh the other person did
and then he
um you know repeated it uh but he
definitely
he was trying to get that read into the
record yes uh for sure
and so uh yeah you can imagine one
again the meme speaking insolently to
the
bitcoin community was you know made him
very very well liked
uh but also too was um it does go back
to this idea almost of
uh if you and i sat down with 10 ceos
and we interviewed each one of them and
then we went in a room and we
deliberated and we said we have to pick
the person who's going to be the most
successful
one of the inputs not all the inputs but
one of the inputs would be who's the
person who we believe has the best
ability to
raise capital recruit people and tell a
story
to the world that will get them to
follow and so somebody like elon would
probably be the best example of this
when you have decentralized products you
have no kind of leader
right in the sense of somebody who is
financially
ascribed to be that leader and kind of
the the executive decision maker
so what you have to do is you have to
look at these technologies in these
communities and say
well which volunteer teams or which
technologies have been able to coalesce
these groups around it
and in some way build the same level of
engagement
and protection and things like that and
so
you actually get tribalism but you also
get things like
[ __ ] coin because what it does is it's
not only a
um kind of verbal attack towards
uh others it's a rallying cry
for internal what's so funny is that it
was started with the bitcoin community
talking about everybody but now you've
seen adoption in other communities who
use it
you know basically say well we're not a
[ __ ] coin it's the it's the next guy
yeah i mean the meaning to be honest
it's
it's one it's off it's sometimes misused
i think like with anything it's like
people adopt memes that
used to be brilliant or still brilliant
and they're just not good at using them
so they become
mean but when you do
with with grace it can tear down an
argument
and at the same time have like love
and respect underneath it i mean it's a
beautiful dance they have to be good at
like you know people just can suck at
communication and even
uh like even a powerful weapon like a
meme in the wrong hands
just uh fires in a way that doesn't get
anything done
but this is like a war of humor and
memes it's kind of fascinating exactly
like you formulated that there's
asymmetry of power so you have to have
guerilla warfare in this
internet game especially when there's no
leader
like you said in a distributed culture
here that is um
is really important i think is from a
society standpoint
we've become very soft and very kind of
coddling
and not in um not in a way that's like i
think people take this argument like too
far sometimes but what i mean by that is
um
it's almost like if you're the person
who holds somebody accountable you
become the bad person
right if you're the person who um says
hey
you know that's wrong you're the bad
person right
and so in a world where i think in um
this kind of influencery
you know all positive if you have any
negative you know feedback or
constructive criticism like you're the
bad person
uh it's the ultimate echo chamber right
and so i think that what the bitcoin
world does
in some crazy crazy way to look at it
is bitcoin is ultimately about truth
not about narrative not about feelings
or emotion it's math yeah you look at a
blockchain
and you can prove something or you can't
and so naturally people who are
attracted to that have a very similar
approach in life yeah right
they say hey you made x claim prove it
and as you can imagine you know a great
example is like the financial media
meets bitcoiners and it's a bloodbath
right in kind of the the arena of ideas
because
what do they do the financial media is
used to the soft
you know opinion pieces etc and
bitcoiners show up and they're like
uh here's data point a b and c here's
example one two and three and you're
wrong
and then all they yell and scream about
is like uh i'm wrong i'm wrong i'm wrong
like
you can't say i'm wrong and like no like
disprove what i just said
and so you get in this like very very
weird it's fascinating it's a
fascinating benefit but
i i do want to say it i've been watching
this
it's kind of interesting i think that
the pursuit of truth
through like tearing down bad ideas
can be done with grace and to do it with
grace requires a lot of skill
like what people don't realize about
disagreement
they think that disagreement is easy
like
they they see the the the lies or the
inaccuracies in the statement
and and they just think they can say
wrong
yes you can say that but if you want to
be effective
it requires great skill like you look at
i don't know um
a beautiful uh verbal [ __ ] poster which
is christopher hitchens
right it requires a lot of skill
through your words to tear down an
argument
to criticize and to take a step towards
truth
uh what i'm disheartened by internet
culture like the negative side
is people don't put a lot of effort in
their tear downs
like into your [ __ ] posting into your
memes
you should put effort and see it as a
skill that you wanna if you want to be a
part of this culture
you want to uh get good at it like any
skill
to 10 000 hours like get improved
deliberate practice self-criticism all
of those things
just because you're anonymous doesn't
mean
you won't get deep joy and actually have
an impact on the world if you get
good at [ __ ] posting but but but i think
this is
really really important right because
you're right in that uh it's all about
intention versus action
if your intention is to uh tell somebody
that they are wrong
in an effort to get them to see the
truth yes
that's very different than if your
intention is to tell someone they're
wrong and hurt their feelings yes
right and so when you can unpack
intention in action
you really quickly can tell what
somebody ultimately is trying to
accomplish
i also think that one of the craziest
things that i've seen play out
is uh memes when i use that term i'm not
just talking about like a
static photo right when i'm talking
about these elaborate uh kind of edited
videos and kind of all this stuff
when done right it is
uh the most articulate
way to deliver a blunt message and it's
done in such a way that is humorous and
entertaining
yet really hammers the point home and so
it's a skill set that many people don't
have i don't make those i'm
assuming you don't make them either
right i see them i share the ones that i
like
right uh but it does take practice
and you can tell look there's people who
are fantastic meme lords
right and there are people who
absolutely suck at it
and it's like anything it's just how
good are you at communicating
and i've heard the idea a bunch of times
so i don't know who to kind of credit
for it but
uh whether it's emojis it's gifs it's
memes whatever
this is the extension and evolution of
just hieroglyphics
right yeah like like we have been doing
this for literally
centuries it's just that now we're doing
it on the internet and you can press a
button and go to millions and millions
of people immediately
you